I don't know what is wrong with that man
to to not see that two elections were
run absolutely horribly the Democrats
absolutely outworked the Republicans
they made the Republicans look like
fools and it was sign the significant
portion of it was ground game I believe
that that Donald Trump would have won in
2020 had it not been for the Republicans
being so bad at their job because they
let the Democrats do uh change the the
laws in in no no no in Pennsylvania they
were in on it in Pennsylvania the
Republicans teamed up with Democrats to
change the rules in violation of their
own Constitution well and Ron McDonald
knows and Trump knows this too that the
RNC needs Trump way I believe Trump
knows things I think I think I we have
to look back at the debate right Ron
McDonald puts out this first statement
being like it would be a mistake to miss
the debate this is a bad idea but they
know they need Trump to bring in the
viewership that's how they are going to
generate money off fundraising right
every fundraising email is get your
Trump gold card